>> Laura: JUSTIN MOMENTS AGO,
HOUSE G.O.P. RELEASING THE TEXT
OF THEIR NEW IMMIGRATION
PROPOSAL EXPECTED TO BE BROUGHT
TO THE FLOOR AS EARLY AS NEXT
WEEK.
WOW.
WHAT'S THE RUSH?
AMONG THE HIGHLIGHTS: ENDING THE
CONTROVERSIAL POLICY DOES CATCH
AND RELEASE ENSURING MINERS WHO
ENTER THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY ARE
NOT SEPARATED FROM THE PARENTS.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO DRAW MORE
PEOPLE AND PARENT CALLS FOR AN
END LOTTERY SYSTEM.
BUT INSTEAD REALLOCATE FOR
55,000 VISAS TO SUPPOSEDLY A
MERIT-BASED PROGRAM.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH CONGRESSMAN
RON DeSANTIS.
AND MONEY FOR THE WALL, BARELY.
25 BILLION FOR THE WALL.
RON, NO E-VERIFY WHICH I'M TOLD
DOESN'T MATTER I THINK IT
MATTERS.
THE CHAMBER DOESN'T LIKE
E-VERIFY.
E-VERIFY MEANS YOU DON'T GET TO
WORK UNLESS YOU ARE VERIFIED TO
BE LEGALLY IN THE COUNTRY,
CORRECT?
CHAMBER DOESN'T WANTED.
>> IF YOU ARE DOING AN AMNESTY
THAT'S 1.8, MOVING MORE MILLION
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT
IN THE BULLETS.
>> IT'S GOING TO CREATE AN
INCENTIVE FOR MORE PEOPLE TO
COME ILLEGALLY.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE E-VERIFY TO
KIND OF REMOVE A DISINCENTIVE,
THAT WALL, EVEN IF IT'S A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT AT THE WALL, AND
I'M NOT SURE IT IS, IT AIN'T
GOING TO BE BUILT IN A DAY.
YOU NEED TO STRIP THE COURTS OF
JURISDICTION.
THIS WILL GET TIED UP FOREVER
WITH THE WALL.
WITHOUT E-VERIFY COMING OR GOING
TO HAVE A BORDER SURGE LIKE WE
HAD IN 2014.
THAT OBVIOUSLY IS GOING TO HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE MOVING.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE PRODUCT ACROSS THE BORDER.
DRUG CARTELS.
>> Laura: 293 PAGES.
WE HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE THING.
>> THE GOODLATTE BILL HAS WHAT
WE CAMPAIGNED ON.
THE GOODLATTE BILL AND CHAIN
MIGRATION.
WE DO THEY SAY THEY WON'T GET IT
THROUGH.
IT'S NOT GOING TO PASS THE
SENATE.
PROBABLY WILL PASS THE HOUSE,
ALTHOUGH PAUL RYAN IS GOING TO
BRING IT NEXT WEEK.
GOODLATTE WAS INVOLVED IN
RUNNING THE NEW BILL.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS OR NOT.
>> WE NEED TO DEFUND SANCTUARY
CITIES.
WE NEED E-VERIFY, END CHAIN
MIGRATION, GET RID OF THE VISA
DIVERSITY LOTTERY.
MAY PEOPLE GO ON RECORD.
IT'S NOT A POPULAR VOTE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT EVEN IN THE
DEMOCRATS DISTRICT, PEOPLE WANT
E-VERIFY.
IT'S NOT EVEN A PARTISAN THING
AT THE GRASSROOTS LEVEL.
>> Laura: BUSINESS DOESN'T
WANT E-VERIFY SO THE MONEY IS
COMING INTO THESE CAMPAIGNS.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO CHECK THE
IDENTITY OF PEOPLE.
>> THAT MEANS IT UNDERMINES THE
RULE OF LAW, HARMS TAXPAYERS AND
LOWERS WAGES FOR AMERICANS.
>> Laura: BUT THEY WILL SAY
IT'S THE BEST WE CAN DO.
AND IT DOES ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHAIN MIGRATION.
WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH IT ADDRESSES.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE AMNESTY
COULD REACH PARENTS AS WELL.
IT'S NOT JUST THE DREAMERS.
PARENTS ARE INCLUDED.
>> IT'S GOING TO THE SENATE AND
EITHER DIED OR THEY'RE GOING TO
MAKE YOURS.
THOSE WERE THE ONLY TWO OPTIONS.
THE SENATE AIN'T GOING TO JUST
PASS THIS.
SO YOU'RE REALLY RUNNING A RISK.
>> Laura: DEVIL'S ADVOCATE.
THEY SAY THE FREEDOM CAUCUS
PEOPLE, YOU NEVER CAN GOVERN.
YOU SAY YOU WANT TO GET
SOMETHING DONE BUT THEN WHEN YOU
CAN GET SOMETHING DONE, LIMIT
CHAIN MIGRATION, BRING DOWN THE
VISA, YOU SAY NO, WERE NOT GOING
TO DO IT.
>> THE GOAL IS TO END ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THIS WOULD FEEL MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THINGS LIKE E-VERIFY.
WILL IT WORK?
YES OR NO.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT HAS
GOT TO THINK LONG AND HARD ABOUT